thank you for joining us at noon I'm  John langler this afternoon a piece of  Lake Mead Boulevard is now back open  Metro Police shut it down over U.S 95  for nearly 10 hours but the question  remains why detectives say this all  started at about 12 30 this morning at  the site you're looking at there near  Charleston and Cimarron officers at the  time say they were following up on an  investigation when they found a car with  three suspects inside the car sped off  and crashed here at around Lake Mead  Boulevard and us-95 about two miles away  one of the suspects was killed it's  still though unclear what the three  people were suspected of doing